[Aplausos]
esta soy yo
siempre escuché que yo no era fotogénica
y ustedes van a entender porque aquí hay
algunas fotos mías donde no se ve la
sonrisa carencia de gracia de
espontaneidad soltura alegría aquí estoy
estarán de acuerdo conmigo en que yo no
era fotogénica ni de adolescente ni de
joven esta era mi expresión
estuve convencida de que yo no era
fotogénica lo creí y lo asumí como parte
de mi ser en esencia como si así hubiera
nacido
los niños cuando nacen son seres divinos
llenos de amor listos para amar y listos
para ser amados son alegres son
espontáneos
pero al mismo tiempo son vulnerables
necesitados
muy dependientes dependen de los adultos
que los cuidan para que los vean pero
que los vean no nada más en su dimensión
física sino en esa dimensión más
profunda que es la dimensión emocional
pero como nuestro cuerpo si se ve y las
emociones son intangibles no somos
atendidos prioritariamente en la
dimensión emocional lamentablemente
porque es precisamente la dimensión
emocional la que tiene más impacto en lo
que será de nosotros en el futuro es la
clave del desarrollo
los niños llegan a la familia nacen se
van integrando en cada dinámica familiar
y buscan cubrir sus necesidades
buscan mirada buscan cercanía buscan
afecto buscan la disponibilidad
emocional de la madre sobre todo sin
embargo como no existen las personas
perfectas no existen las madres
perfectas los padres perfectos ni las
familias perfectas la perfección no
existe entonces lo más seguro que tiene
un bebé cuando llega es carencia
carencia tienen necesidades y no se
pueden cubrir no hay quien las cubra
todas de tal manera que el niño cuando
no tiene las necesidades cubiertas las
emociones lo avisan las emociones avisan
que no tienen cubiertas las necesidades
y comienza se comienza a ver al niño
enojado o triste o asustado
este médico canadiense gabor mate
experto en adicciones cuenta una
analogía que a mí me gusta mucho
imagínate que vas a un país en el que no
hablan tu idioma y tú tampoco entiendes
su idioma y tú tienes una necesidad y
quieres cubrirla digamos que tienes
hambre vas a hacer todo tipo de ademanes
para que te entiendan y dependes de la
comprensión que tenga el otro de tus
gestos para que cubras tu necesidad bajo
riesgo de que si no te decodifican lo
que estás actuando te quedes con la
necesidad sin cubrir los niños no dicen
sus necesidades las actúan y dependen de
la conexión que tengan con sus padres y
de la comprensión que los padres hagan
de su actuación para que en el mejor de
los casos puedan cubrir sus necesidades
pero eso no es lo común lo común es que
los padres
no conocemos las necesidades de los
niños y a veces aún conociendo las no
podemos cubrirse las porque nosotros
mismos no tenemos necesidades cubiertas
de tal manera que los padres ante la
actuación de los niños lo que hacen es
nombrar lo que ven
pero nombran lo que ven en la dimensión
física y en una dimensión digamos como
lineal de causa-efecto si el niño llora
es un llorón
si la niña es buena si la niña no se
enoja es que es buena
si la niña sale serie en las fotografías
no es fotogénica
nombramos lo que vemos en la dimensión
física y lo que el niño escucha lo asume
como parte de su ser y se va
construyendo un falso yo se aleja de su
autenticidad se aleja de lo que se llama
el ser esencial este es un proceso que
todos vivimos todos vivimos los seres
humanos tenemos dos necesidades básicas
la primera necesidad es la necesidad de
apego el apego es esa necesidad que
tiene todo ser humano de estar cercano
en proximidad a otro ser humano para
sentirse protegido y seguro esta es una
necesidad tremendamente importante es
una necesidad de sobrevivencia el ser
humano es la criatura más vulnerable más
indefensa de toda la creación
necesita del apego con otro ser humano
para sobrevivir apego la segunda
necesidad es la necesidad de
autenticidad
ser yo mismo de saber que siento y de
saber y de poder expresar cómo siento
dos necesidades tremendamente
importantes apego y autenticidad
necesidades evolutivas sin embargo si un
niño en aras de ser auténtico muere se
muestra como es digamos se muestra
enojado y se encuentra con padres que se
enojan más fuerte que él o que cuando él
se enoja le retiran mirada presencia
cercanía el niño sacrificar a su
autenticidad en aras de tener apego
el ser humano es un ser adaptativo y
para adaptarse reprime reprime su ser
reprime sus emociones la represión
emocional es el mecanismo adaptativo por
excelencia del ser humano nos adaptamos
reprimiendo y dejamos de ser nosotros
nos alejamos y entonces nos encontramos
con esa necesidad de evolutiva de
supervivencia nos encontramos
desarrollando mecanismos o formas de
actuar o formas de ser y de pronto
decimos cosas como es que yo soy una de
esas personas que no me gustan los
conflictos
nos habremos preguntado qué modelos
habré tenido yo de solución de
conflictos que ahora no me gustan
porque le tengo miedo a la confrontación
que creencia tengo de que no tengo
derecho a cubrir mi necesidad
o sigo con la creencia de que soy la
niña buena y la niña buena no se enoja y
no tiene no se mete en problemas
tenemos creencias limitantes que nos
auto definen yo te invito a que ahorita
pienses cómo te auto defines como te has
definido seguramente vas a constatar que
eso que eso precisamente que con lo que
te defines es lo que otros nombraron de
ti pero lo que no nombraron ahí está ahí
está en tu ser auténtico solo que no se
nombró
soy mamá de cuatro hijos cuando nació el
primero mi esposo y yo que vivíamos en
una casa de dos pisos
decidimos poner una reja como ésta al
pie de la escalera en el segundo piso
para proteger al niño de que en su etapa
de gateo y de caminar no rodará por la
escalera y tuviera un accidente esta
reja a mí me dio mucha seguridad me
permitió sobrevivir a esa etapa de
crianza
y luego llegó la segunda y luego llegó
la tercera y diez años después del
primero llegó el cuarto y la reja seguía
ahí
y pasó el tiempo y la reja seguía allí
ya era parte de la dinámica y a veces
esa reja obstaculizaba el tránsito
fluido por la escalera pero ya ni cuenta
nos dábamos eso que en algún momento fue
un recurso para sentirme segura y
sobrevivir a esa etapa de la crianza hoy
era un obstáculo en mi vida
y así nos pasa
es importante desafiar creencias es muy
importante desafiar creencias hoy
médicos y científicos de muchas
disciplinas han desafiado una creencia
mayor con la que se han formado la
creencia del determinismo genético hoy
se sabe se publica se divulga de muchas
maneras que muchas enfermedades y
trastornos no están determinados por los
genes
son el resultado del ambiente en el que
esa persona se desarrolló los primeros
tres años de vida particularmente
nuestro yo no está determinado por
nuestros genes
es el resultado del ambiente en el que
nos desarrollamos de lo que otros
nombraron de lo que nosotros actuamos y
de lo que nosotros creímos de eso
si estás de acuerdo en que conocimiento
es poder vas a estar de acuerdo con yo
dispensa que dice conocernos no se
empodera
estamos en la era del conocimiento la
ignorancia es una elección
yo he hecho el recorrido hacia atrás
para ir a construir me mi propio yo
ahora de manera consciente y desafiado
creencias y por lo menos una de ellas es
que yo también puedo ser fotogénica
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]